they're fighting Ordinary
People that's one way of putting it but
it's not true even now as all of this is
happening and these videos are
everywhere fared Zakaria on CNN brought
on Mustafa barudi who's a Palestinian I
think he's in the cabinet uh and listen
to what he says and and F just lets him
say it I mean absolute
abject
horse go the what Hamas is doing
is they
targeting Israeli
civilians women children grandmothers
they are not uh is that is that is that
not a classic Terror isn't that classic
terrorism they're not fighting the
Israeli government they're fighting
Ordinary
People that's one way of putting it but
it's not true I think Hamas mainly
attacked military establishments many
military installations and most of the
people they they have arrested and and
taken as pres war war prisoners are
military people I do not accept
attacking any civilian uh I do not
accept that Israelis attack our
civilians but look at what Israeli
planes are doing now in Gaza they they
are bombarding houses they're bringing
down to earth and you've SE you've shown
that on your on your screen look I get
that that guy is just a piece of you
know propagandist liar right like that's
what he's there for he's doing his job I
have a bigger problem with fared Zakaria
who puts these people on and fed's been
doing this for years with these people
putting on these apologists to lie they
are telling you don't see what you see
with your own eyes it doesn't even
matter what fared said after that that
you let this person on that guy should
never be on CNN and fared should be
fired but I get it I get it like that's
not going to happen this is how the
machine operates um but they are no
they're they're civilians they're
civilians yeah yeah the 250 kids who
were at the Rave that you just mauled
down the 40 kids that were beheaded
babies not not not kids toddlers babies
babies